[Musique]
les essentielles du sénat
construire la sécurité sociale
écologique
moins d'un français sur deux est en
bonne santé à 65 ans
les facteurs de risque environnementaux
tels que la pollution l'exposition aux
substances chimiques ou le changement
climatique contribue à la survenue de
plus de 100 maladies ou traumatismes
or l'état ne s'est pas dotée des outils
prospectifs pour faire face à la
survenance plus fréquentes d'événements
climatiques
cela met en péril la soutenabilité
financière de la sécurité sociale
avertit la mission d'information
protéger et accompagner les individus en
construisant la sécurité sociale
écologique du 21e siècle
notre système de protection collective
doit développer une culture de
prévention d'adaptation et de résilience
tel est le sens du rapport adopté par la
mission d'information est rendue
publique le 7 avril 2022
la rapportrice mélanie vogel déplore le
fait que les politiques de la santé et
de l'environnement ne soit pas mené de
manière coordonnée
pour amorcer un changement de paradigme
il est indispensable que la stratégie
nationale d'adaptation au changement
climatique fasse l'objet d'un débat
annuel au parlement
l'étude d'impact des projets de loi doit
donc inclure un volet climatique et de
santé environnementale
par ailleurs il est proposé que france
stratégie coordonne l'élaboration d'un
plan d'adaptation de notre système de
protection sociale en intégrant une
cartographie des risques
il convient en outre de mieux former des
acteurs de la santé à l'impact des
facteurs environnementaux sur la santé
est de développer un programme national
ambitieux de recherche en santé
environnementale
en matière de financement la mission
d'information préconise notamment
d'adapter la fiscalité environnementale
afin d'assurer le financement de la
sécurité sociale écologique
le rapport était en outre une série de
mesures pour améliorer la prévention et
le suivi de la santé au travail
il faudrait mieux prendre en compte
l'impact des épisodes de fortes chaleurs
et des pics de pollution sur la santé
des travailleurs
enfin le rapport évoque le droit à une
alimentation saine et la nécessité de
passer d'une logique d'assistance
alimentaire à une logique
d'accompagnement par l'alimentation
il préconise ainsi d'approfondir le
nutrisse corps en opérant une
distinction entre produits bruts ou peu
transformés ou ultra transformé
pour en savoir plus consultez la
synthèse du rapport
[Musique]